hi i'm rishabh i graduated from saint
lawrence college back in 2018 with a
diploma in computer networking
i landed my first internship with one of
the software companies in kingston
ontario
after two months i was hired there as
technical support specialist
how i was introduced to the cloud during
my time there i was introduced to cloud
the company used it frequently
we had a sas solution for customers and
hosted around 600 of them in aws
it was fascinating to me
given my curiosity i was able to
convince my manager for a test account
to play around
i started launching some linux instances
in the development environment
little did i know how interesting this
journey was going to get
during this time i discovered free code
camp so i started learning web
development during my leisure time
along with some web dev projects i
explored cloud and how i could leverage
different services to host a website
landing my cloud job
my company had an opening for a position
in the cloud operations team
i'll be honest even though i lacked
confidence i'd give it a shot anyways
my interest and willingness to learn
cloud convinced the team that i would be
a good fit for the position
if that opportunity was not available i
would have practiced more with some
hands-on projects deployed them in cloud
and with some updates to my resume i
would have started applying to external
junior associate cloud roles
free code camp played a role with web
development skills that i learned i was
able to create my first portfolio site
and hosted it in cloud
finding good learning resources to fill
a skill gap is the key there are a lot
of resources like free code cam and
google cloud skills boost
so with some basic knowledge of aws
understanding of cloud computing
concepts and my portfolio project
hosting i was able to secure this
position
i believe it was the project that
convinced the interviews to say yes
i had prepared detailed documentation
and architecture diagrams
they asked why i chose certain cloud
services over others questions such as
what is load balancing how i was
implementing it on my portfolio site why
i chose a specific load balancing method
over others
how would i host it on a vm and why i
didn't host my project on a vm instance
it's important in an interview to have
deep understanding of cloud concepts and
how you applied them to projects that
you have listed on your resume but what
about cloud certifications i do believe
that certifications help you land your
first cloud role that being said it only
helps to a certain extent
what i mean by that is if you only have
the certification and lack actual
knowledge about cloud concepts it will
be hard to land a role
i only had an aws cloud practitioner
certificate when i applied for the cloud
engineer rule
having good projects will help you not
only understand the concepts better but
would also demonstrate your skills and
expertise to the employer
so how did my helpdesk skills land me a
cloud rule so if i were to look back on
the journey and steps i took to get into
the cloud i would say start with some
training material familiarize yourself
with cloud computing concepts and
services that cloud provides
google cloud skills boost is a great
tool as it not only has video based
training but hands-on labs to go along
which i think is really important you
need to get your hands dirty by
deploying vms setting up vpcs
configuring databases and deploying load
balancers
after training i would suggest building
a project that is available publicly on
github and is hosted on cloud
so people can view it and see it working
live
document that project well have
architecture diagrams and explanations
on some of the design decisions
this will help you demonstrate that you
have deep understanding of cloud
concepts
and finally i would recommend is to take
an associate level certifications like
the google cloud certified associate
cloud engineer as now you should be
confident having gone through training
and having some hands-on experience
now you're almost ready to apply for
cloud roles after grooming up your
resume
including the skills you have learned
experience in health desk that will help
you in your cloud role and projects that
you build along with certifications
you